and you too thank you for taking the
time and giving us so much of your time
I wonder if we could walk along the
corridor and you could I I noticed some
of these um pictures of
ukrainians
um Heroes yeah tell me about them
what is here that's you know I think
that
you you get to hear our veterans from
from
2014. veterans from the war in Crimea
bearing witness to the challenges the
latest conflict is having on this
battle-hardened Ukrainian regime
security is extremely tight around the
president as you would expect our
passports were checked several times
phones and laptops removed and stored
well away from president zielinski
eventually after making our way through
airport style scanners we were guided
along darkened corridors past bulging
sandbags and closed protection officers
bristling with weaponry and into these
gloomy halls
in English
sorry yes and this is I mean this is
dark as well and what is one of the
things that strikes me
um
deficit because of Iranian attacks right
by drones
Russian attacks by Iranian entrance I
think it will be correctly but for us
the same if Russia use uses Iranian
drones it means that Iran Iran
helps
that's it yes what's the normal day like
for you here how do you live your life
here that is my life now
yes how I live here yeah I mean what do
you do you do you eat at The Palace you
eat and I work here do you manage to go
get exercise here what do you do yes I
have exercise yes it's very very morning
early in the morning I love to read and
have some exercise right yes of course I
I wake up yeah then get up well
six six in the morning and love to read
if I have some time
talk me through your day briefly you you
get up you exercise and work that's it
work during till night and that's it and
sometimes yes bad and sometimes you have
to get up
through the night yes because of some
you know phone calls or very important
things or or decisions
um can we sit down and have a chat yes
please fantastic thank you
we wanted to know more about the
comedian turned world leader who's not
only a politician but the father of two
children one a 17 year old student and a
ten-year-old son who talks to his father
about events on the Battleground rather
than fun in the playground
um talk to me about your family your
family life you talked about them having
to leave just before when the war was
breaking out you see them very rarely
I I think the question is to my family
am I good
my like Father the attitude to me I
think it's also not
um I don't know if I can use such word
not polite to speak about me to speak me
about me in such case but I I think that
they love me
and it's not about thinking I feel it I
think these feelings is the best one and
I want to save it yes and that is the
most important I have
so my my family how often do you manage
to see them how often do you mind
oh but
uh
often my wife then my children it's a
it's a bitter that I can see my children
you know once per
now now it's often than from the very
beginning last two three months we have
we have once per 10 days
I can see my my children one for two
weeks I can see
have some food have some talks and I can
I can see my daughter because she's
she's a student
from this year and that's why I I often
see her than my son he smoke guy
he's just young he's just young he's
he's 10 years old what do you talk about
of I'm I'm I think I I I'm listening
talking he's he's he is so good he is so
sweet and and he's 10 years but he's
thinking like
a strange strategy uh tragedy for all
our families I mean that through Ukraine
because all our children adults and all
of them they speak about war they speak
about when we will win they know it
exactly it's better then they know uh
better than me I think when you will win
the world yes they they will win
tomorrow and it's about our children and
they know everything you know about
what's going on we need tanks what the
chancellor is waiting we need we have to
push we don't have F-16 we have to push
them so it's very interesting
I I mean that but it's interesting and
from one side from Another Side like I
said to you
it's tragedy that they they speak about
it not about children's not about their
you know games between each other not
about soccer yes no no dialogues about
soccer no that is the difference
but we will we will change this
situation I think